all right game three of this four game
series tomorrow tonight we'll try to
cool down these hot hitting mets miami
trying to get back on track
after having lost four straight and now
seven of nine following a 7-1 start to
the season pablo lopez hopefully just
the man to do it out on the mound
donnie's saying before the game today
that right now you've got to consider
pablo lopez the ace of your staff and
when you send your ace out there you
expect six or seven really good innings
except give you a chance to win and
that's what pablo will try to do here
tonight against one of the best if not
the best in the business right now jacob
degrom going for the mets
and a swing and a miss and joyce is down
on the 99 mile an hour fastball and
degrom's got his first strike out of the
night
99 miles per hour strikeout number one
on the night and now in the 22 and two
thirds innings he has struck out 29. two
on two out one at two to anderson and
the slider in there strength three
called he got him back-to-back
strikeouts for degrom to strand a pair
in the first inning
so wilson almost with an opportunity to
get the mets on the board his biggest
problem has been in these spots he's
just two for 19 with runners in scoring
position he takes that one out to right
field tagging at third is alonzo he
comes down the line brenson's throw will
go to third and guillory moves up as
well it's a sacrifice fly for wilson
ramos to get the mets on the board it's
one nothing new york that's a start for
wilson that was a difficult slider down
and away and he went with it
there's a strikeout on the fastball so
that is number four for pablo lopez one
away in the fourth talked about pablo
getting a little you know extra on the
outside corner and i think tom smith the
rest of the at-bat was just convinced
that he's got to cover more than his
fair share on the outside parts
against his wind-up hands to the chest
his pitch
swinging a miss strike three 95 mile an
hour fastball over the outer half and
alonso swung right through it so lopez
is fan five he's retired the last eight
batters he's faced and he has another
one two three inning we go to the bottom
of the fourth jacob to grom in the mets
with a one-nothing lead brian anderson
will lead off from miami past the mound
behind the back guillermo on the
backhand and the throw scooped out of
the dirt by alonso beautifully done for
the first out there's guillorme showing
off his skills
made that look easy and then alonso
digging it out on one half
trevelli strikes out
and that's five strikeouts for the
ground jake has struck out five tonight
and make it six as he gets alvarez with
that high fast ball
just what the birthday boy ordered
six strikeouts for the grom one-nothing
mess
it's the fifth inning in miami where the
mets have a one-nothing lead against the
marlins they'll try to get a little bit
more done against pablo lopez
ground ball
forsyth gets to it gets up slips and
still gets them at first base what a
play
by logan forsyth
footing gave out right as he was about
ready to make that throw and aguilard
dug it out
now logan did a fantastic job staying
with it maybe a little payback for
guillorme he's been taking hits away
from the marlins well take a hit away
from him you're right nice job by
aguilar good stretch
now with men at the corners dior maze
coming up
and he pulls it in that same spot and he
gets a base hit and in comes dominic
smith and it's two nothing new york luis
guiorme comes through again an rbi
single for guillermo in its two nothing
mets right before that pitch cervelli
motioned to the right side because he
was saying we're going to throw a pitch
in and down so the ball is more apt to
be pulled and it was
and right through that vacated area and
that's going to be all for pablo lopez
two outs in the seventh another
opportunity for the marlins
that one gets away from ramos alvarez
will score easily
and up to second goes vr so the marlins
get on the board after a wild pitch
yeah this is a huge break for the
marlins
ramos decided to go to the backhand
chose not to keep the body in front
and this ball is going to get to the
back stop caught him on the shin guard
and the mets have two men on for dom
smith
dom lines it in a right center field
that's a base hit around third and
heading home is conforto he will score
jd goes to third dom slides in at second
with his second double of the night this
one drives in a run and it's now three
to one new york
dom smith just keeps cranking out the
extra base hits that's his 21st run bad
at end of the year and another extra
base hit so his last 18 hits
15 of them have been for extra bases
and more importantly a big insurance run
dom now has 10 doubles for the year dom
smith has just been a revelation
ground ball
alvarez comes home with it and they will
get the out
i'll tell you what alvarez has done it
twice tonight just not the play you'd
think would be made and he has made it
look easy both times well how about he
made it look easier this time i mean
this is an incredible play i mean with
all of his momentum going into basically
left field throwing on the run
cervelli securing that one hop throw
that's slowing down
i mean davis is out at home standing
because there's he's there's no way
there's a throw coming home he knows how
that ball was hit he saw the whole thing
happen in front of his eyes he's think
he thinks he's standing scoring uh
scoring standing up
all in one
way inside and did that get him it did
so aguilar will score on the hit by
pitch
and the marlins are within a run now
a 3-1 from diaz is down low and the
marlins will score another run a bases
loaded walk
and conforno cracks one out to center
field that goes vr near the wall and
it's out of here
michael conforto puts the meds back in
front
a big clutch to run ninth in a home run
from michael conforto
fourth home run of the year for conforto
and the mets go back in front five to
three
there is the biggest hit of the season
for the mint so far
after they let the lead get away in the
eighth conforto gets it back in the top
of the ninth
3-2 coming from diaz to dickerson
in there for a call strike three and the
ball game is over diaz strikes out the
side of the ninth conforto with the
enormous two-run homer in the top of the
ninth and the mets after letting the
lead get away
stay away from lugo and win the game